hey what's going on is Pilbara it's time
for the thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast and I am
just checking in on you just checking
yeah I'm just checking in to see how you
are your work weeks going who's kidding
who I'm just checking in because I don't
want you to forget about me what was the
name of that guy on Monday he was
yelling it's Bill burr Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcast and I throw out my back
yep Jesus bill a manager of your
advanced age how did you do that
stretching you know my left shoulder I'm
[ __ ] working through it right I've
been going to the gym going to the pool
I'm that I'm at that age that's how old
I am you know when you're younger you
look at a pool like oh my god imagine
the fun we could have splashing about
when you get older you just like oh man
that it's readable therapy is all you
see I could [ __ ] get my shoulder I
can lift my arm up to the side without
it [ __ ] shooting pain down to my
wrist so whatever I had a little bit of
frozen shoulder frozen you know which as
you know anybody else rotator cuff issue
you can you can end up with one of those
because you limit the range of your
movement of your arm because it [ __ ]
hurts and then what happens is if you
don't do the full range just I don't
know what happens schmutz grows over
your tendons and all of a sudden it
[ __ ] hurts to move your goddamn arm
frozen shoulder everybody I have the
same thing that Jeffrey Dahmer used to
have for dessert Jeffrey Dahmer as a
doctor what can I do for you I got
frozen shoulder sounds delicious sorry
you would not want to say that the
Jeffery job you would not want to come
in in July
put it that way and talk to dr. Jeffrey
Dahmer sorry anyway so last night I was
on the couch I was trying to improve my
range of motion and I started watching
this series succession or as I call it
how dare you you son of a [ __ ]
that's why Satan you want to watch an
episode of how dare you you son of a
[ __ ]
great [ __ ] show great acting and all
that type of stuff but I can never
remember I don't I keep forgetting if
it's succession or a secession but it's
succession so I just go hey me you want
to watch much episode I'm gonna get you
you son of a you know I know making fun
of it but I absolutely love it it's a
[ __ ] awesome show so anyway I'm on
the couch and I was just trying to move
my arm in circles you know what I mean
and I was in a weird position on the
[ __ ] couch and elves and everything I
felt a little bit like it went out I
said all right and I got up because I
made pumpkin bread last night two loaves
of pumpkin bread I mean could I sound
like an older man now I'm talking about
physical therapy and a pull throwing out
my back and I was making pumpkin bread
can't you just hear the sound of my
slippers shuffling across the linoleum
floor sit there my [ __ ] dirty old
robe with my old man balls hanging down
to the [ __ ] floor so I got up to have
a piece basically I [ __ ] it up - I
always do a couple early I'm lying this
year I did a couple early because I'm
going on the road here for a few days
and you know I felt bad or whatever I'm
having the time of my life being out
here I told you I got my daughter a
tricycle and she's totally figured the
thing out and we were riding around in
the driveway doing circles she knows how
to steer it now she goes frontward she
goes backwards and her big thing is you
know I run away from the tricycle keep
turning around in horror going no no
says she loves that game now she goes
dad I ride tricycles and dad I go no no
no
cutest thing ever
so yesterday we've been doing that all
week so yesterday actually got on my
bike which I bought with my paper route
money way back in the day in the early
80s and I was thinking as I was getting
on it who ever thought that I'd ever
ride this thing with my beautiful
daughter was an awesome moment and I
know what you guys are thinking Jesus
Christ bill what the [ __ ] you riding a
bicycle for that you bought in the early
80s because you know what the great
thing about a bicycle is you never have
to throw it out there is no [ __ ]
reason ever to throw out a bike unless
you got hit by a car on it and then they
bent the frame and you somehow survived
you lift your leg up and did that roll
up and over the car landed on your feet
you know the big Tom Selleck mustache
maybe it did that but most people don't
and yeah I remember being in New York I
saw one that was all [ __ ] banged up
and frosted it's like Jesus Christ I get
it the guy died that I have to see the
twisted up bike anyway Jesus Christ I
want for my cute story too [ __ ]
frightening so I don't know if that's
how it started with my back I don't know
what the [ __ ] happened so but I'm doing
what I always do with my back as I just
go through the basic yoga poses and I
just keep you know put my arms up and
just hang from a [ __ ] doorframe I
don't put my weight on it cuz I'll [ __ ]
my shoulder up what's really like you
know if I could be an arrogant ass it's
like flying instruments right you're in
the clouds and you lose a couple of
gauges and then you got to use other
gauges for other [ __ ] you know what I
mean you lose your altimeter so now you
use your [ __ ] vsi I've been going
through the the pilot the whatever the
the [ __ ] test prep book I outlined
all eight chapters I [ __ ] crush
chapter one chapter two was whether I
had to stay on that for like two three
days now I feel confident about that and
then I got to chapter 3 which was the
instrument
I just got [ __ ] crushed I didn't know
[ __ ] you know it [ __ ] kills me these
[ __ ] [ __ ] who fly airplanes
they're such [ __ ]
kids everything's like geared to them
everything in my life I've always been
the [ __ ] left-handed guy looking for
a pair of scissors back in the day when
I was trying to make a snowflake you
know when I wanted to cut around the
trace thing for the [ __ ] a there was
nothing then you put the right-hand
scissors in your left hand and they
wouldn't [ __ ] cut so then I had to
[ __ ] learn how to cut the right every
[ __ ] I'm always the other they had
[ __ ] red hair but I was a white guy
so I got the Toxic male [ __ ] white
[ __ ] as I stood there clearly getting
chased around at recess right based on
the cut my own color of my hair and my
pasty legs right an unseen minority
running by burning up in the Sun in
front of everybody so now we get to this
[ __ ] test-prep thing everything's
geared towards fix wings or [ __ ]
planes you know and then if it's a
helicopter question they're like oh uh
you know rotorcraft only but I got to
[ __ ] learn how you [ __ ] slip and
skinned and Bank and all of that [ __ ]
but you know what after my meltdown then
after this one I just say [ __ ] this I
pull up a couple of YouTube videos and I
just learn about it and now I've become
fascinated by airplanes and specifically
how much cheaper they are because
there's so much less losing moving parts
I should say and they're way [ __ ]
faster and you can go farther
so I'm sitting here you know the only
thing I could afford to get in a
helicopter actually I can't afford any
of them because my wife doesn't want me
to get one which means okay whatever
money I saved up to buy a helicopter I'm
gonna lose in the divorce well like a
helicopter it's just like you know he's
sort of limited how far you can you
could fly one across the country but at
my age I wouldn't want to do it it's
like Ryan for you motorcycle guys I'm a
hardtail is that what you call it
so anyway but the you know those
airplanes where you get a [ __ ]
airplane fly 30 grand a used one right
I know a lot of people that allow
[ __ ] use everybody that's fine
[ __ ] things that maintain hopefully
crews right out to vague all of a sudden
it becomes like everything's within
reach you know if you had a [ __ ]
airplane right thirty thousand bucks and
you lived in Los Angeles and you want to
go to see one of the last Donnie Murray
shows at the Flamingo like I do you
could jump in your [ __ ] plane and you
could get out there and I don't know
what like a little over an hour cruise
up to what it nuts right over the Mojave
Desert you know not stupid bill old
left-handed orange headed Bill not him
he chooses are to have [ __ ]
helicopter [ __ ] 90 knots [ __ ]
eighty knots and on r22 what the [ __ ]
headwind looking down at the highway
watching cars pass you you know but I
can hover over this family of grizzly
bears seven hundred feet above noise
abatement they want to scare the animals
sorry anyway what the [ __ ] was I talking
about alright my back feels a little bit
better I can't sit like this because
this [ __ ] it up oh Jesus Christ
that's when you know you're [ __ ] up
when hunching over feels better than
standing up straight and you know what
the best thing about the back is is it's
a complete [ __ ] mystery it's like the
common cold right now I'm gonna get a
bunch of people writing in got up you
know a lot of deal you want to drink
some camomile tea and take the last
three sips throw it over this is key now
throw it over your left shoulder now
hold the cup the way to the cup without
that tea in it okay with your right arm
crossed over your left shoulder I cannot
stress that enough
it's what's gonna free up your East six
you don't know and I don't know all I
know is I just do the yoga poses until
it [ __ ] goes away that's what I do
alright I tell you guys how my wife took
over the [ __ ] couch that we have it's
unreal
she bought this big long stupid
that [ __ ] heats up we have a [ __ ]
l-shaped couch in the way it's set up is
you can just lay on one part of it and
your head straight ahead looking at the
TV it's [ __ ] perfect slip off into an
old man nap wake up what'd I miss
what'd I miss you know Trump still
president where am i right
nope my lovely wife went out and bought
this [ __ ] thing I swear to god it's
like sleeping on a [ __ ] coffee table
and she told me last night well lay on
there play on this it's [ __ ] it heats
up it'll be good for your back it's like
it isn't I sleep on it my [ __ ] ass
hurts you know it's like I I like I'm
sitting on a slab a line slime stone she
loves it can't get enough of it but he's
a [ __ ] thing
she loves it so it's gonna stay there
you understand if if she didn't love it
and I got it that thing would have been
in the [ __ ] trash a long time ago so
now that's my leverage as far as buying
like a little two-seater helicopter
which I if I did I would buy that
[ __ ] Capri the French one because
that guy took apart the r22 and found
all of anything that he thought he could
do better and he [ __ ] did it's a
little more expensive I don't know my
buddy who's trying to help me out
because you're much better to buy a used
one that can hold more than [ __ ] two
people you know have more inertia on
your [ __ ] main rotor blade so you
don't have to [ __ ] freak out if you
had a [ __ ] engine failure so my guy
you know there's some merit to that so
this is how I'm arguing with my wife I'm
going like you can [ __ ] take over
couch and I can't buy a helicopter I'm
never gonna buy a helicopter I'm never
gonna get one I want to know you know
what [ __ ] that I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
get one this is what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna get my [ __ ] instrument rating
then I'm gonna get my commercial rating
and then I'm just gonna start [ __ ]
I'm gonna have I'm gonna start flying
tours and the tours are gonna be where I
want to go that day hey you guys want to
fly out to Arizona for the Arizona
Cardinals versus the [ __ ] New England
Patriots all right you guys play for the
helicopter I'll pay for the fuel pump
and I'll basically fly for free that's
what I'm gonna do
are you bill I don't know that's the
fantasy anyways the NHL started last
night that and the Bruins their first
ones tonight but but up but up the
Bruins shaking off that game seven loss
hope we got a little bit tougher you
know I should have watched last night I
didn't have you know I bitched about the
[ __ ] DirecTV yesterday you know what
goddamn it I got a [ __ ] email you
just [ __ ] give me any NFL package
charge me I'm not looking for a deal
[ __ ] [ __ ] and while you're at
it throw in the center rice package
there we go
bing-bang-boom daddy TV that's what it's
called in my house Oh watch puppy dog
pals we're watching daddy TV you know
when I put on hockey and then I take out
our little [ __ ] we got this little
setup there one of her aunt's got her
you know two little goals that thing we
get down on your knees and you got the
little stick you play [ __ ] hockey she
loves it I have to put on a knee pad for
my right [ __ ] knee this is all just
you know pathetic my body's breaking
down you know but my mind's still there
and I just feel people they're not
treating me the same and it's torture
Bruins have the Dallas staff tonight and
this is our first year with
what's-his-face Renee what's-his-face
isn't gonna be singing the [ __ ]
national anthem what will we do without
that for broto
although I don't think he's saying
throughout the playoffs did he I can't
remember I'm old oh right in the center
of the back I got to tell you the center
of the back is not as bad as the lower
back lower backs the worst you know
that's when you literally brushing your
teeth and you put your head down to spit
in the sink and you just like and it
echoes in the bathroom you [ __ ] scare
everybody I think the house is haunted
so anyway I'm going to be watching that
tonight and then I have a set I think I
want to say at The Improv tonight down
on Melrose for the conan takes over
Comedy Festival Conan O'Brien the great
Conan O'Brien another redhead another
unrecognized minority you know you know
I mean I understand not seeing me but
that guy's like six six you know how do
you not see that guy explain that to me
yeah so I was in a bad way last night
was [ __ ] hilarious my back was out my
shoulders [ __ ] up and then I [ __ ]
out making the pumpkin bread as I was
putting it in a you know I put it on the
top rack I'm like isn't it supposed to
be in the middle of the oven I left it
on the top rack and then when I was done
the [ __ ] outside was cooked the
inside wasn't I had to put it back in by
the time the inside was cooked the
outside was a little crunchy that's all
right
so I had two slices of that you know cut
up two slices moaning you know as I'm
walking in my [ __ ] back I sit down
you know my wife eats one of her mic how
is it and I got a look at an eight
second pause and I'm just like Jesus
Christ just put me out of my misery she
goes the insides good alright I know I
[ __ ] it up right so I ate the other
slice and a half and then like I got the
worst [ __ ] heartburn I think cuz I've
been eating so well I got the worst
[ __ ] harp I mean I'm literally just
break it down so it's over I had
everything in my life last night except
a [ __ ] walker and a goddamn colostomy
bag so I got the worst heartburn Sania's
like you know I'm like there we got any
tums and Rolaids you know which is a
clear [ __ ] sign that you need to
either change your diet or not eat
whatever the [ __ ] you just ate ever
again right so she goes we don't have
any and I go alright what's a natural
way to get rid of the heartburn so they
had that apple cider vinegar to sip that
so she took out a shot glass you know
one of the ones that reminded me of my
drinking days which is coming up on 45
weeks ago Oh freckles its lucky seven
weeks away from doing the ear I said I
was gonna do it god damn it I'm going to
do it now after that I don't know what I
don't know what I think I'm gonna go to
my neck
birthday when I turn 52
all right cuz I always wanted to go a
whole year January December and I also
wanted to go a whole birthday where I
could be like you know I didn't drink
when I was 51 the whole [ __ ] year but
if I get to 52 then it's kind of cool
cuz I'll be like I haven't drank since I
was 50 now I'm on a little bit of run a
little bit of run here right you sit me
down you know like they like the way
they did to Eli Manning am i voluntarily
gonna do it just do a beer and a [ __ ]
shot take myself out the way Cal Ripken
jr. did bill are you comparing yourself
to elite athletes yes I am you could
tell by my physical condition that I've
discussed on this podcast I think I'm
right there with them is there anything
worse than ending your career in New
York City it's just the [ __ ] worst
because everyone just starts [ __ ] on
you everybody forgets about what you did
for the franchise and then because it's
New York it's like oh my god you know is
this the worst retirement everything
that happens in New York that's all they
do is just [ __ ] you know over and
over and over again like I swear to God
if the New York Knicks ever did what the
San Antonio Spurs did over the last
couple of decades we'd never hear the
end of it
as opposed to the Spurs who it's just
like a blip on the radar
even the [ __ ] what the Steelers did
in the 70s in Pittsburgh right you still
hear about that if they if the
Pittsburgh Steelers were the San Antonio
[ __ ] breakfast burritos whatever the
[ __ ] they would be called down there
right you would [ __ ] the the the San
Antonio Texas the San Antonio
death penalty's
trying to thank all the great things
that I've seen I had a great breakfast
burrito last time I was in San Antonio
it's [ __ ] delicious that's what you
got to do when in Rome right you go to
go to Italy and get some Thai food
you're not you're getting the pasta yeah
no one wouldn't know him would have
[ __ ] remembered watching what the way
Eli Manning has been treated I swear to
god you would think that he didn't
[ __ ] beat Bill Belichick in the
Patriots twice with Tom Coughlin you
wouldn't think that I never saw a guy so
recently winning a room the last five
years of his career all he did is give
him [ __ ] they gave him [ __ ] all last
year he spent last year on his back
looking out his [ __ ] ear hole he had
no protection whatsoever you know he's
such a [ __ ] class act he never said
anything you know never made that face
like I'm blaming my [ __ ] teammates
shaking his [ __ ] head never did any
of that just took it like a man and now
you know this other kid he's running
around he's won a couple games for him
he's been nothing but supportive total
100% class [ __ ] act and I like that
he's he stayed Eli while he was in New
York you know what I mean he didn't
switch over to some [ __ ] what's that
goddamn store Barneys he didn't go there
and buy a bunch of shitty then he kept
wearing his [ __ ] Dockers same way
same way he came in um so I don't
understand why now my throats all [ __ ]
up and I know I barely smoke cigars
anymore I mean I'm literally falling
apart everybody this next podcast I'm
gonna do is gonna be a benefit for me
for me the benefit podcast
Patrick Ewing the way they treat him
Derek Jeter Derek Jeter's Derek hurting
the lineup I kept writing all that [ __ ]
towards the end it's just like there's
just such fat [ __ ] [ __ ] in New York
you know in the New York sports media
they're just a bunch of fat
[ __ ] [ __ ] I don't know maybe they
have to because there's so many papers
so they just have to focus on the
[ __ ] negative all the time but I
don't know you gay as a Red Sox fan if
I'm [ __ ] sitting there going Jesus
Christ take it easy on Derek Jeter I
mean you're a little out of line No
so anyway I'm kind of glad I'm not
living there right now watching them
[ __ ] [ __ ] all over that guy and then
of course this guy's won two games and
you know how the New York media is so
now then a is this guy the next [ __ ]
Joe Namath did why eight it'll just come
on to the gridiron to [ __ ] wins that's
all it takes
okay I think that that's why New Yorkers
don't travel as well I love [ __ ] not a
man I'm just having a good time
I know [ __ ] rap before it's always
trash in Boston so I can't have one
podcast where I just [ __ ] make fun of
New Yorkers New Yorkers are the worst
travelled people ever I've know I said
this a million times that's why you know
cuz everybody blows New York you don't I
mean so then all the guys walk around
they had this attitude like they were in
Destiny's Child you know which by the
way I am so sick of them glorifying
divas you know what I mean these these
goddamn feminists they're out there all
the time go like you know if a woman
does it she's a [ __ ] if a guy does it
you know that if he gets respected it's
like what up vh1 divas they're all
clearly walking around acting like a
bunch of [ __ ] they they just take your
night what kills me is they cannot get
in the crowd cannot get enough of it
they see the attitude you know this
person wouldn't even give you the
[ __ ] time of day they just in the
crowd yeah they can't get enough treat
us like [ __ ] I know I do not understand
that [ __ ] crowd whatsoever
vh1's the [ __ ] that's what I would have
called it don't listen to me okay just
don't listen to this [ __ ] my back's
[ __ ] killing me and I come walk it
out right now to the garage where had
been banished because I cursed too much
on the podcast I mean you wouldn't you
wouldn't be thinking the way I crushed
this mortgage that that that not me I'm
the same guy [ __ ] have to come out
here to my goddamn garage which is a
[ __ ] you know no heat no a/c it's
like I'm living in a looks like I'm
living in a log cabin that's made out of
stucco no I [ __ ] up so I walk out
here and this is [ __ ] cat that keep
you know it's not our cat you know cats
they don't give a [ __ ] okay they cross
lines like a [ __ ] hot chick you know
making things start swinging on bouncers
they're still getting a free drink they
don't give a [ __ ] right it's goddamn
[ __ ] cat comes in it takes a [ __ ]
[ __ ] right in front of my [ __ ] door
into my garage that's how my day started
all right hobbling up across the little
brick patio every [ __ ] step cuz in
one hand I have my [ __ ] laptop right
in the other hand I would have [ __ ] I
don't know what the [ __ ] I had something
lighter so it was making me not balanced
I don't know what the [ __ ] that was
doing to my back and then what do I see
is cat [ __ ] I thought these things
[ __ ] [ __ ] in a litter box I'm
assuming it was a cat who knows what the
[ __ ] it is I don't know so I had to go
back in the house shuffle back in the
house and pick up some cat [ __ ] alright
let's let's let's do some [ __ ] reeds
here for the week alright Jesus Christ I
probably lost half my listeners on this
podcast but just picked up bengay as a
[ __ ] sponsor alright all mats
cryofreeze no Jesus can I put this on my
back ah pronounced cryofreeze it's how I
said it all right
okay evidently this stuff is [ __ ]
amazing Oh max health has come to the
rescue
uh oh my god I hate when they try to
write in my [ __ ] voice get ready I'm
gonna sell this [ __ ] out of this I can
handle this just whether you're an old
fart like my my boy Tom Brady they
literally wrote this for me Wow it's
adorable
I can analyst old fart Tom Brady is
reverse aging he runs a faster 40 now
than he did when he was [ __ ] 22 I
would love to be an old fart like him
you know what's funny is you actually
he's so old right now you hear the
announcers for the commentators
resenting how good he still looks
because he's all he's about about five
years younger than the youngest
commentator it seems I don't know why
Tony Romo is younger but generally
speaking all right all right all right
what am I doing here uh whether you're
an old fart I can't I came to read this
cuz they wrote all his [ __ ] I'm a trashy
Tom Brady you [ __ ] [ __ ]
huh what are you a Rams fan he beat you
twice in the Super Bowl you don't like
it all right whether you're an old fart
like me or someone who just deals with
constant joint pain back pain muscle
soreness oh this works on back pain I'm
gonna go [ __ ] try some it's been
working wonders on my shoulder finding a
natural pain reliever that actually
works is almost impossible you can try
the icy hots you can try bengay and
they're just at ease the pain comes back
in an hour or two Oh max cryofreeze
really works it's a non prescription
pain relief roll-on goes on like a
chick's deodorant formulated to block
pain reduce inflammation and improve
joint health does it work on back pain
you said it did how the [ __ ] do I do it
I don't have the mobility in my
shoulders to get to my middle of my back
that's what I have a wife for I'm gonna
walk in there can you put this on the
middle back and what she's gonna do
she's like
really you can't do this
I was just exhaling oh my back all right
all right
Oh max cryofreeze is a 100% natural CBD
power remedy that works instantly and
the relief lasts ups to eight hours all
you have to do is roll it over wherever
it hurts and the pain immediately goes
away all right I'm telling you go try to
find another CBD product like Oh max
cryofreeze good luck these guys talking
[ __ ] everybody's in the weed business
here man
it doesn't make you high though all
right Oh max health is giving my
listeners 20% off a full bottle of
cryofreeze pain relief roll-on plus free
shipping I'll tell you this personally
I've used it on my shoulder it [ __ ]
works great this discount also applies
towards any products site-wide you'll
notice they have a sleep and stress
remedy CBD product be getting that right
after I'll be getting that right after
recording this - no I I don't have a
problem sleeping I have a back problem I
have a shoulder problem this is [ __ ]
stupid this is [ __ ] stupid all right
I'm using I'm literally I'm actually
using the [ __ ] product and what do
they do they trash my quarterback and
then they start saying I'm getting [ __ ]
that I don't need okay I can't be in
this [ __ ] business saying that I
[ __ ] have problems sleeping they're
gonna think I'm gonna nod off on set and
then they're gonna get somebody else to
do those eight lines in that movie I am
at a critical point in my career
cryofreeze all right you need to go to
home you need to go - Oh max health calm
today unless you don't want to and enter
the code birbee you are are I'm telling
you this is one of my favorite sponsors
and I want them to continue sending me
free stuff well [ __ ] I need more of
it so go - Oh max oh ma X health calm
and enter BRR - get 20% off cryofreeze
and site-wide - terribly written
sentence - get 20% off not only
cryofreeze site-wide you get 20%
- that's Oh max health calm and use the
code BER manscaped everybody now that
you've numbed up all your joints and
they're slowly healing you can finally
use your arms to reach down towards your
junk all right and trim your man Bush
trim the your hedgerow his Robert Plant
would say you got a bustle in your
hedgerow there's a company I know where
the pubes have to go and you're trimming
your hedgerow man junk
sorry just when you didn't think
stairway to heaven could become more
annoying there's some orange pubes I
know manscape support for Monday morning
podcast comes from manscaped who is
number one in men's below the belt
grooming manscape offers precision
engineered tools for your family jewels
exactly this is IFR below the belt above
the belt is VFR you can trim your
eyebrows who gives a [ __ ] right you
cannot [ __ ] up when you down near your
[ __ ] balls alright talk about the
time you've nicked your balls shaving
and wanted better options oh yeah every
time you fold back when I was a single
guy any time you nicked your balls
shaving that was the time where you
hooked up and some lady went downtown
all right acting like a Labrador
Retriever and you had to sit there
[ __ ] in stinging pain while you tend
to try to maintain an erection was this
the [ __ ] story you wanted me to tell
because you know I I don't know I didn't
get any guidebook
guidelines here that's why manscape has
redesigned the electric trimmer their
lawn mower 2.0 has proprietary skin safe
technology so this trimmer won't Nick or
snag you nuts the worst word buy your
[ __ ] balls is snag I mean snip Utley
sounds like it's [ __ ] over quickly
snag it's like a shudder
[Laughter]
manscaping accidents are finally a thing
of the past
and don't use the same trimmer on your
face as you're using on your balls
that's just nasty we've all been guilty
of that man escapes also has the crop
preserver an anti chafing ball deodorant
and moisturizer you you already put
deodorant on your armpits why are you
not putting deodorant on the smelliest
part of your body I don't have sweaty
balls man I don't have that problem my
balls have [ __ ] cool cool is a
[ __ ] cucumber my balls melt I see hot
he got dead no I wouldn't work melts
melts tonight cools down the hot part I
see hot out jeez this is a [ __ ] it's
a brain twister get 20% off free
shipping with code with the code burr at
manscape calm always use the right tools
for the job
your balls will thank you yeah you know
something if you use this [ __ ] hopefully
you know I went to a dermatologist one
time right this is just all my health
issues and I had like on my leg I was
flying all the way to Australia I
thought I had a dry pass just patch of
skin or something like I don't what the
[ __ ] I was a gross so I was using this
[ __ ] ointment and wasn't working what
the [ __ ] was it that Jesus is the most
critical part of the story because the
lady the dermatologist was going I'm
gonna give you something you know a
prescription thing that's gonna get rid
of it but you have to watch out you
can't use it too much because there's a
steroid in it or something I don't know
what the [ __ ] it was right but what I
was using that oxy something that oxy
ten that's for [ __ ] pimples not oxy
what the [ __ ] is it begins with a no I
was using it on there and she goes you
got to watch out I had a guy come in
here and he was using that on his balls
she didn't say it like that cuz he
sweated so much down there and he was
using talcum powder and then all these
women you know we're finding out that it
was a [ __ ] carcinogen or some [ __ ]
like that so he switched to that [ __ ]
the other [ __ ] and he got stretch marks
around his [ __ ] balls not like his
balls cuz they're all wrinkled but like
his [ __ ] you know the whatever you
call the Tapia legs that are abeam your
balls he got stretch marks down there
and I actually laughed which made it
weird for half a second because doctors
care all right hello fresh everybody
what is hello fresh what with hello
fresh all the reason why I got it cuz it
was a steroid in that [ __ ] sorry with
hello fresh America's number one meal
kit get easy seasonal recipes and pre
measured ingredients delivered right to
your door all you have to do is cook and
enjoy home-cooked meals made simple
hello fresh makes cooking delicious
meals at home a reality regardless of
your comfort in the kitchen from
step-by-step recipes to pre measured
ingredients you live everything you need
to get a WoW worthy dinner on the table
in just thirty minutes that my me at
schoolhouse wrong
so if you're happy hooray or sad ah a
frightened
eek or glad hey or excited whoa that's
it right Wow I'm sorry break out of your
dinner and rut with hellofresh
20 plus seasonal chef curated recipes
each week there's something for everyone
from family recipes to calorie SMAT and
vegetarian vegetarian cool and fun menu
series like Hall of Fame and craft
burgers
oh hello fresh has more five-star
recipes than any other meal kits so
you'll know you'll get something
delicious add extra meals to your weekly
order oh and as well as well as yummy
add-ons like garlic bread and cookie
dough easily change your delivery food
preferences and skip a week whenever you
need host must mention a minimum of four
bullet points from the sections outlined
above I assume I read them all host must
voice unique hello fresh vanity URL
specialty
I'm going to do this for $80 off your
first month of hellofresh
go to hellofresh comm / b you are r 80
like star 80 / 80 and enter bur 80
repeat offer why don't you just write it
twice copy and paste for $80 off your
first month once again go to of
hellofresh go to hello fresh comm / / 80
and enter / 80 as the promo code alright
that's it for the for the advertisements
this week that's also it for this
podcast we're gonna have a little bit of
music here and then we're gonna listen
to a bonus episode of a Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Monday
morning podcast you guys have yourselves
a wonderful weekend you [ __ ] here we go
bro here we go dad Bruins going for this
seventh Stanley Cup this year can we get
over the hump can we get a bunch of
goons that can run a [ __ ] goaltender
and win a cup like those [ __ ] [ __ ]
the st. Louis Blues right
god bless their fans they got to see
then win a cup but that Jesus Christ
that was like watching that watching
them win the Cup last year was like
watching a [ __ ] [ __ ] tone-deaf
group of people try to sing a [ __ ]
song not even they just played old
school hockey
I still cannot get over that they were
allowed to play 80s Early 90s [ __ ]
hockey the exact [ __ ] that they were
trying to I guy does it I have a little
hangover from that loss sorry that they
were allowed to play that the exact kind
of hockey that they [ __ ] penalized us
out of and we show up with an Olympic
hockey team hey let's play a little
[ __ ] you know no touch icing we
literally got we got beat last year the
Boston Bruins got beat by a team playing
Bruin hockey that's look I'll never I
don't know I don't know anyway I hope
you got a little more teeth in the bear
this year all right that's it
go [ __ ] yourselves have a great weekend
you [ __ ] and I'll I'll talk to you on
Monday
oh I'll be at the Patriots Redskins game
so look for my bald head in my [ __ ]
aching back at RFK Stadium wherever the
hell they played out
oh by the way can we talk about that
lady the [ __ ] there's a woman out
there she [ __ ] was married to a guy
who was a billionaire she's getting a
divorce the guy wrote her a check just
under a billion dollars and she turned
it down
now I know what a lot of people are
thinking what a [ __ ] gold-digging
[ __ ] this is right up Bill's alley I
know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna tweet a
[ __ ] link to this article and this
will get him going on the podcast and
then he'll have a [ __ ] fit and I'll
laugh is I'm sitting in my cubicle well
surprise surprise I'm not really having
a [ __ ] fit about this because I don't
think it's about the money this is the
deal this broad
all right this [ __ ] Twinkletoes here
all right old little [ __ ] sugar tits
here she married this guy this guy was
worth 50 million bucks
he was an oilman get off my [ __ ]
property right now global warming
good I like that there's a hole in the
ozone layer makes me feel like I'm
closer to God right he's an oil man hey
I'll tell you what mr. president I mean
know why I have to call you mr.
president I [ __ ] put you in office
with my goddamn money
look at me when I'm talking to you oh
bomber all right my granddaddy put that
dictator in [ __ ] power and he was
supposed to give us our little gold
little [ __ ] they're right he's supposed
to give us our liquid gold right he
ain't doing it no more you got to go
over there you got to take that [ __ ]
out you understand me I'll give a [ __ ]
how you do it he's an oil man it's a
[ __ ] oil man all right he's got Slim
Whitman on the laserdisc right dude
that's Irish what was the [ __ ] Slim
Whitman he sold over nine million
records anyways I'm all over the [ __ ]
map here see I'm back to me I'm not
looking at the TV anymore
so this [ __ ] guy he's got he's got a
fifty million dollar business this he
already has this and this woman does not
sign a [ __ ] but he doesn't sign a
prenup with the woman according to her
she didn't take the billion dollar
payout because now 26 27 28 [ __ ]
years later they going for Dwarfs this
guy's company is worth 20 billion
dollars according to her all right hey
here's the thing she's like I was with
this guy and I supported him and Bly
held down the [ __ ] home front and all
that that's got to be worth something
this was [ __ ] crazy to me it's like
you know with all due respect sweetheart
this guy made 50 million without you
okay look I could see if the guy had a
couple hundred grand in the bank all
right maybe all right whatever you know
what I mean you make fifty million
dollars give me a [ __ ] break you
started out with nothing and you're
worth fifty million dollars you [ __ ]
you know what you're doing at that point
once you have 50 million dollars that's
that's when that's when you got your own
you can starting to have your own plane
you're in a gated community
you got your own security system you
know you [ __ ] kill somebody and the
cops go down to your house and they're
talking to your lawyer in the driveway
is you're sitting there eating [ __ ]
escargot in an English muffin and
they're asking your [ __ ] lawyer if
you if you wouldn't mind turning
yourself in over the next six seven days
you like that level [ __ ] rich and
once you that level rich its full it's
all [ __ ] downhill you're meeting the
people that are running the world
you meet the people in the Bilderberg
Group you meet the people and the other
group said I don't know about it what
the [ __ ] they talk about but I pretend
like I do you're at that level of
[ __ ] wealth all right so this [ __ ]
guy grows it to twenty billion dollars
and she gets a check for a billion jet
basically and she says she doesn't want
it she wants more so everybody's saying
that she's a gold-digging [ __ ] you know
what I really think it is and she's
saying that she supported them and
helped the bill say go [ __ ] yourself
all right let's let's just say for
whatever [ __ ] reason I met an unknown
Lady Gaga in the East Village 1012
[ __ ] years ago
right and she's down there ripping off
Madonna songs or whatever I'm like you
know what there's something about her
though you know she's got nice legs he's
got a nice ass I mean I don't like the
imperfections I like that giant no let's
look at me I got red [ __ ] hair it's
falling out I think we can make a good
couple you know we're both the mess two
negatives make it positive we'll make a
beautiful baby so I start [ __ ]
hanging out with the next thing you know
we fall a lot Garrett
so then we think all right you know we
get married
okay and let's just say what out
whatever I'm doing I'm [ __ ] I make
keys that's what I do that's my job okay
and she's out down and she's down the
village and she's [ __ ] you know she's
making her own meat dress you know she's
going out she's making money in a coffee
house and she goes right to the deli and
she buys more meat she's investing in
herself she's building her career she's
playing the [ __ ] piano she's coming
home and she's like what do you think of
this and I'm like it sounds good honey
right I'm over there I'm knitting a
[ __ ] sweater you know I got a pot
roast in the goddamn oven or whatever
looking and then she becomes Lady gaga I
get to quit my [ __ ] job mr. Gaga
I get to go on Oprah and sit there
silently you know as Oprah talks to lady
for [ __ ] an hour and then finally she
says well what do you see it her and
then I already have some pre-written
speech about how I'm Gaga about Gaga I'm
gaga for gaga whatever the [ __ ] happens
right and let's just say in the end of
all of that I'm walking down the [ __ ]
hall blinded by her gold records
platinum records and all that [ __ ] every
morning when I go to brush my teeth I
got a [ __ ] I got to put on my my
amber visions just to get there so I
don't [ __ ] walk into the walk-in
closet instead of the bathroom let's say
at the end of that she gets sick of me
and she kicks me to the [ __ ] curb all
right now let's say she's worth 100
million dollars and she turns around and
says I'm gonna give you bill I'm gonna
write you a check
let's do the same thing let's say 220
billing just say she's worth 20 million
and she says bill I'm gonna give you a
million dollars and you know what I'm
gonna say I want to say thank you lady
gaga
it was awesome I enjoy
I was just making keys I wasn't gonna
make a million dollars in my lifetime
all right
I'm gonna take this money and I'm gonna
pay my taxes on it I'm gonna get myself
a little [ __ ] house you know and I'm
gonna make keys in the back of it I'm
gonna get my life back and I'm gonna
find I am God knows you gave me plenty
of [ __ ] and I would buy it you know what
I would do with that I would go buy a
[ __ ] everybody needs keys touchdown
who the [ __ ] was that who just scored
that Nate soldier just scored his first
touchdown ever nice 23700
did we match up better against the
Packers so anyway look at our two
cheaters talking they're on the
sidelines two convicted cheese that was
a nice play that was a nice play how do
you like the video I love the video um
anyways you gotta have a sense of humor
but you don't [ __ ] team don't you
most people don't but I do um anyways so
let's go back here yeah she gave me a
million bucks what I would do is I would
find a house that cost like I don't know
like a hundred fifty grand you know and
I would put down a ridiculous amount of
money on it and then I put the rest of
the money away and I would start cutting
keys again out of the back of my house
and I get that business going and I
would [ __ ] build it up and then I go
on to set of farmersonly.com I go on
like key makers only dot-com and I try
to meet somebody else that's what the
[ __ ] I would do I would never try to
take her money I'd be like you know what
I know I gave you support I know I said
that was a beautiful song I know you
wrote a couple songs about us instead of
dear Ben you wrote dear bill I get it
but I can't sing I can't play a [ __ ]
piano who's kidding who we both know why
I lived the life I lived for the last
ten years it was because of you Lady
Gaga and to think I got to live that
life and in the end of
you're gonna give me a million bucks to
leave yeah you're a [ __ ] Saint
continued success thank you for that
million dollars and I would [ __ ]
leave right I got too much [ __ ] pride
to sit there if somebody doesn't [ __ ]
want me to then try to take everything
they got I mean just I couldn't fund I
was the second so he doesn't want me
around like all right Jesus I didn't
know I was annoying you I get it
sorry can I grab my things now do you
want to want me to send somebody else
sorry just get the [ __ ] out of there so
anyway so that seems to be you know this
lady here that she got a billion dollars
and she says it's not enough what I
honestly think it is I just think it's
an emotional thing for this woman I
don't think it's a money thing because
you can't spend that he can't spend all
that [ __ ] money right
did you guys they actually showed a copy
of the of the check that this dude wrote
to his ex-wife he didn't write it on one
of those business checks you know that I
sort of extra long and the whole extra
area the memo section that you write
stuff he wrote it on like a personal
little check like the same kind of check
like you know somebody live in a
week-to-week there's little checkbooks
he wrote a check for like nine hundred
eighty nine million eight hundred ninety
nine thousand dollars in thirty one
cents whatever the [ __ ] it was and I
think what he did was this guy's obvious
I don't know what the [ __ ] maybe he's
just good at business I think he just
sat down after they decided on the
number and I bet he did it right in
front of her after 26 [ __ ] years okay
he's walking away he's leaving and he
just sits down and he's just writing
money just to make her leave
and he just sits down and goes scribble
scribble scribble sign sign sign dot the
I crossed the [ __ ] team tears it out
here you go beat it lady I just think it
came across like that and it [ __ ]
pisses her off and she's just like this
is the thing up the worst thing you can
have when a woman's breaking up with you
or if you're breaking up with a woman is
if she's not over you if she's over you
it's gonna go smoothly you don't have to
deal with her [ __ ] you know put
enough you have pet rabbit and a goddamn
Stu alright but if they're not over you
you gotta [ __ ] let him down easy
you can't just push him down the
emotional elevator shaft all right
you're gonna have a major [ __ ]
problem and I think this guy he just
[ __ ] fired off to check like he was
paying another bill and she just was
insulted by that and she's think doing
the math and I had like you know this
[ __ ] gonna I actually talked a
little bit about this on the Chris
Layton podcast so I forgive me if
there's a little bit of overlap but I
just want to hear what he thought about
it I think that uh I I don't know I just
think that they they want you they want
you to hurt they just want you to hurt I
don't know what it is not all of them
just some of them and I think that she
didn't get as sad as enough of a
satisfied hurt look on this guy's face
there wasn't enough pain I think he just
treated her like he had to get the
gutters fixed and that some professional
come over and did it and he just fired
off this [ __ ] check and it just
pissed her off well cuz she's more than
taken care of for the rest of her
[ __ ] life anything she could ever
want it's all good but I think the fact
that he still has so much more money and
it didn't hurt him to write that check
that and she knows that he has enough
money to get like you know I mean you
got twenty billion dollars there's like
a Victoria's Secret model that will
pretend to give a [ __ ] about you for a
good year year and a half and you could
do that for the rest of your life as you
ride around in Ferraris now her she's a
woman guys don't work that way we don't
really give a [ __ ] about money you know
one more like enamoured by looks you
know it's both of our [ __ ]
this is whatever you guys are into stuff
we're into [ __ ] you know tits and ass
so which is why you know we will date
somebody is dumb as a [ __ ] rock and
he will also date some ugly old balding
douche you know because they can take
care of it it's kind of what we do so
I'm not really a lot of people wanted me
to go off are like she's a gold-digging
[ __ ] I don't think she is I think she's
I think she's hurt and she's hurt how
easy this guy is just getting over I
know all you guys are sitting there
going like dude what the [ __ ] he's
writing a check for billion dollars I
know that hurts dude you got twenty
billion dollars come on man if that's
true if it's true and you got twenty
billion dollars yeah I'll write you a
[ __ ] check from for a bill that would
hurt me at all there you go
bing-bang-boom bait it whistling Dixie
Jesus Christ the [ __ ] interest alone
on that money hid you by the time you
walk down the driveway or she walks down
the driveway leaving you your money has
probably already made [ __ ] thirty
million dollars the [ __ ] do you care I
know he's probably that's obviously not
twenty billion liquid he's got a lot of
that tied up in Derek's right some giant
[ __ ] ranches some oil rags some
trucks